Donald Trump was indicted he will be
indicted the jury voted to indict he
will be arraigned on Tuesday within
couple hours Donald Trump's I guess
least favorite son Eric Trump goes on
Fox News and he reacts to the indictment
by ranting about CVS and Tylenol now you
might be saying David wait I know about
Advil I know about Tylenol what's
Tylenol I also don't know but here is
Eric Trump ranting about CVS and Tylenol
in response to his dad's indictment it
is every single day and this is a city I
spent a lot of time with you that is
falling apart I went into literally CVS
the other day and you can't buy Tylenol
because it's locked behind these glass
counters because there's so much theft
and there's so much looting there's so
much homelessness and crime but yet
their attention is going after Donald
Trump little girl yeah so listen first
of all you go into CVS or you go into
Walgreens anywhere in this country when
I was just recently in Florida I went in
I had to get my very powerful hair
product it's locked up I had to ask
could you pretty please with the key
open it up for me you go into a CVS
North of New York City as I recently did
and uh the deodorant my girlfriend's
deodorant it's like you know everything
free it's free of soy it's free of of
beef broth there's no beef bro it's you
know one of these hipster uh deodorants
it's locked up somehow I don't think
that that's really the alternative for
Alvin Bragg to be focusing on
compared to the Trump indictment what I
would suggest to Eric Trump is maybe
hold off on these pathetic appearances
because you you really seem unhinged and
you literally went to CVS what does that
mean as opposed to you sent someone I
don't even know what this guy is talking
about lock in folks because what we are
going to see over the next let me think
24 48 so over the next 96 hours leading
up to the Trump arraignment is going to
be increasingly unhinged and the hope is
and I'm not you know people write in and
say David you're hoping that Maga
becomes violent no no no no no no I
didn't want violence on January 6th I'm
against violence I don't want violence I
don't want shootings I don't want
burning I don't want looting I don't
want any of it don't no matter who's
doing it
I hope
that Maga doesn't get violent over this
so far they really don't seem to care
and even when Trump previously said I'm
getting arrested on Tuesday which didn't
happen on that day
um his supporters really didn't seem to
be activating the way he wanted them to
so let's all hope cooler heads prevail
as Justice proceeds let's hope this is
the first of many indictments we're
going to take a break what a day what a
day